there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey there everybody its
episode 127 yeah hey should we do
something for episode 150 like what Oh
No this somewhere my glasses I told them
that he should wear them cuz I look
smarter
well one cuz you look smarter yes and I
said plus if I say something like
earth-shattering you can like whip a
mama off a girl like that's why I'm
sorry I'm sorry if you just listen to
the audio podcast you mister I'm gonna
make that my new thing yeah the hell
yeah yeah he was he was like looking at
a salad before it was like are you gonna
wear those on the show and he's like
glasses making me look smarter that's
why I wear mine I don't need to look
smarter there's another t-shirt right
there you're liking so much work for me
with all these little I was gonna say I
don't I don't wear the glasses you look
smarter I I wear the glasses cuz I can't
see [ __ ] without them I can't read today
we're gonna talk about edgar cayce yeah
somebody like recommended this a couple
weeks back and i was like that it wasn't
even on my list and like i said i have a
humongous list of topics and i was like
this is an amazing thing that i hadn't
written this down because he's kind of
like the preeminent psychic
quote-unquote or see or whatever of the
20th century almost like a prophet yeah
and i feel like um a lot of what we
consider your
standard New Age beliefs yeah comes
pretty much from him or at least he kind
of like codified a lot of it like into a
big thing like you know all his stuff
about I mean he's probably most famous
for like his medical diagnosis but he
also talked about like he made future
predictions he talked about Atlantis
also left behind a foundation that did a
lot of weird [ __ ] after he was gone
including trying including educating
Zahi Hawass yeah action guy who ran the
dams on every [ __ ] History Channel
venturi ever
yeah he's pervious [ __ ] got did some
weird stuff with women and he's on the
run for the last I heard I hadn't like
seen him for he was there's some kind of
corruption going on where he was making
money on the side with you know with his
egyptology gig you know I don't know if
he was selling antiquities I think it
was more like there's a lot of that kind
of [ __ ] I've read a couple books about
that like the shady and together sales
market there's a lot of shady I think he
was mad you know just off the top of my
head if I remember quickly correctly he
was doing weird stuff like stealing
other people's work like they would come
up with the idea and also I think doing
things like giving private tours
underneath the table to like real you
know particularly attractive people and
people that paid a lot of money you know
take you to places where you you really
weren't where you weren't supposed to go
right that kind of stuff so like rich
people making money on so I had to go
put their grubby little fingers all over
show this yeah of course he's pocketing
it that's what last I heard I don't know
but and the the new Egyptian government
was looking for him but it was a Greek
AC foundation that educated him because
that foundation wanted access to the
Great Pyramids of Giza
it's because that well I think it's
because like I said
Edgar Cayce very famously wrote this is
repeated on the website of the
foundation everything like that made
over 14,000 psychic readings about
pretty much every conceivable topic and
one of those was that the Akashic
records or
you know the your great library of human
knowledge or whatever that was like that
Atlantis had stored there or whatever it
was like all human knowledge it was in
between the paws it was supposed to be
like under the right paw of the Sphinx
things like that and then they come in
there with some kind of a sonar device
and they find that there is an empty
pocket in that area yeah I just watched
there was a history documentary that
came out I think it was in 2005 and they
specifically mentioned this and they had
the Egyptologist or archaeologist or
whatever he was and he said yeah we
found what appears to be a chamber like
underneath the paw but they don't know
what's in there or anything like that
and like I said I don't think anything's
come a bit since then because I haven't
heard no there's a bunch of no dig
orders around the real famous stuff
there not a lot of dig around those
areas wouldn't that suck those like if
they because if you did dig there like
what if the Pollock fell in or something
you don't like ruin the [ __ ] Sphinx
they have ways of getting that down the
right way it's just that yeah it's just
that the Egyptian government wants to be
the ones to do it well fair enough and
they don't really have the technology
you know I mean and then you know they
want to do it themselves actually they
say they wanted to do it do it
themselves but I think I think they're
more kind of like we'll screw that we're
making money with all this tourism well
yeah we don't need to be digging we're
making enough money already well yeah
because nobody wants to go see the great
pyramids and the Sphinx and like there's
a bunch of like construction [ __ ] or you
can't go over there or anything like
that I can see what their items here
they're coming along yeah they're making
more money out of people coming to see
it yeah people dig around there's a
bunch of mysterious stuff you know in
the Giza complex you know there's some
underground things they know they know
that there's still a lot of stuff
underneath the ground well yeah I'm sure
there is because you know that was it
that was ancient Egypt became an it's
like room dig all these holes and we got
put cooking ball the body down there and
treasures and all that [ __ ] there's
probably all kind of fun [ __ ] underneath
yeah there's a bunch stuff of King
Ramses made you know and all the his
sons are in this underground complex you
know that that's all excavated now or
most of it is yeah the funny thing is
that that you know the just that I just
previously mentioned the History Channel
documentary about
ostensibly it's about edgar cayce and it
came out in 2005 and i watched it and
the title of it is the other Nostradamus
yeah it's like his name wasn't even in
the title of it right and like the first
10 or 15 minutes of it was actually
about Nostradamus and about mother
Shipton and then finally they got around
to talking about you know edgar cayce
look at me talking about finally getting
around talking like we can't we can't
say that because you know look how long
it takes us to get around to talking
about [ __ ] but I just thought that was
so sad it's like can you imagine I know
he's dead now and he can't like get
upset about it but can you imagine like
you know 50 years from now they make a
documentary about me and I'm like the
other so-and-so I even use my [ __ ]
name that's right sad because the thing
about edgar cayce and everybody that
watches this show knows that I'm like
the biggest skeptic ever I'm very very
skeptical of psychic stuff you know
future reading all that kind of crap so
I don't really put much faith in any of
his readings or anything like that just
because I don't think there's any solid
proof of it but I will say that by all
accounts he seemed like a lovely person
and he really seemed like he was doing
what he was doing because he genuinely
believed he was helping people I mean he
famously like refused money like he was
even like struggling for money most of
his life particularly because he would
not take money for his readings he
insisted on doing them for free yeah and
so that's why he often had to like rely
on investors and things like that who
were interested in his work he would
actually pay yeah so you might take on
us a little bit different I'm not as
skeptical about psychic stuff you know
I've seen it myself you know poltergeist
experiences near-death experience
out-of-body experiences things like
dreaming true or having feelings of
certain things that would happen they'd
happen now I kind of like premonitions
and you know it wasn't just me you know
that the US Army in the intelligence
community was interested in this kind of
stuff and they evidently
used it whether or not they were able to
fully control it you know I don't think
so there was something called Project
Star Gate that the government was
involved in but with a remote viewing
you know so I believe it exists it's
just that there's a lot of charlatans
that try to make a buck off of it it's
easier to yeah I mean it's like magic
tricks to fake some [ __ ] make a quick
buck and move on I think most of the
people that can do it do it without
trying do it by accident it's just a
part of the natural course of your life
and I don't and I don't think they can
do it on command I agree with you
spontaneous yeah you just spontaneously
have a dream and in that dream you get a
message from somebody who is dead or
from from a relative and then you find
out later that that person had died yeah
even know that person was dead stuff
like that you know it's a you know you
know people have done it yeah and I'm
not disputing that that happens because
I know that it does and a lot of people
have had those experiences I've had
those experiences I just like you said I
don't think the reason I'm skeptical of
psychics or people that call themselves
psychics are because these people are
claiming that they can essentially
control it that they can tell you what
your future is gonna be or they can
suggest you know what I mean yeah and I
don't think anyone can do that I think
if people do have quote-unquote psychic
abilities it's probably just something
that happens spontaneous and comes to
them about them right like you know
whenever somebody comes from the outside
of a situation there's don't worry I'm a
psychic I can solve your problems and
then they do a reading and they'll tell
you where the dead body was but you know
where the dead body was buried that kind
of [ __ ] I don't I'm very very skeptical
of that kind of stuff maybe it could
happen every now and then but most of
the stuff that's ever happened to me and
other people who've reported it it
sounds kind of matches up with kind of
kind of stuff that's happened to me it's
it's not like that it's something
personal about you in your situation and
it just comes out of left field
like dreaming true they're gay that
feeling that something's gonna happen
like man I got a feeling that you know
I mean that the car is gonna break and
the next day it breaks yeah even though
there was no warnings that kind of stuff
yeah and I feel like you're way more
likely to have quote-unquote psychic
feelings about your situation or people
that you love you know your family your
friends stuff like that I mean I that's
again why I'm kind of skeptical about a
lot of Edgar Cayce stuff because most of
his [ __ ] was about people he never even
met he just did stuff through letters
and you know he didn't do a lot of his
readings in person so I kind of feel
like that's I got an exact example I had
a dream that I was flying like a dc-10
or a dc9 like like a plane a cargo plane
you know jet but you know passenger jet
yeah and I had a I had a dream that I
flew it into I think it was a big ol
male building you know I mean like a big
gigantic post office right I woke up the
next day and 9/11 happened I have heard
a lot of people say that that they
dreamed about a plane crash or they
dreamed of hitting a building yeah and I
watched that happen live on on the news
yeah I didn't see the first plane hit
live the second plane of Saudi I don't
think anybody saw the first plane hit
yeah I was sitting there watching it
watching the Fargo dome and I think that
buildings gonna fall and then the second
plane came to hit it Nick oh man this is
on purpose you know I had a dream of
crashing a plane and that a lot of
people had that type of dream like yeah
that happened and you know what's
interesting is when I used to go back
and forth you know you know many years
ago I used to be married to a Welsh
person so I used to go back and forth to
Wales all the time and I lived there for
a brief time there was a very famous
like a mudslide like a rockslide it's it
wasn't actually mud it was like coal
slag and it came down a hill and buried
a school and killed a [ __ ] ton of
children and I actually went to the
cemetery there where they buried all the
little kids and I was kind of interested
in I mean it was like a horrifying
experience so I was like kind of
interested in the history of that and a
parent
the same thing happened the night before
that happened a bunch of people had
dreams about black stuff just like
coming over them and them not being able
to breathe and stuff yeah makes me
wonder if there's some kind of a group
unconsciousness you know I mean like a
group unconscious between people and
maybe you can get collective or maybe
even just to you that's really not that
weird because like some other animals
have that type of like maybe something
birds could do yeah or even you know or
even animals even insects and stuff like
that that are like kind of like hive
mind early collective brain type of
thing there might be some of that yeah I
was thinking that at the time yeah and
back on that dream and I was like man
then you know maybe something to do the
group consciousness yeah space-time
continuum yeah
and that was actually something that
Edgar Cayce kind of advocated then you
know everyone was one type of thing I
don't think he used those particular
words but the still kind of an activity
between yeah and he was I think I think
he was kind of ahead of that might go
into like the quantum consciousness and
coin and quantum soul theory yeah that
Roger Penrose and what's his name or
working Stuart Hameroff it would hammer
off where your consciousness is an
entirely housed inside you know it's not
some jindo it's also in kind of like a
quantum field around you and
interconnected with other things and it
could be quantum in quantum entanglement
with things that you come in contact
with and which means people and objects
so it's kind of like a quantum Internet
yeah pretty neat like I said doesn't
sound completely yeah so like some
animals would have yeah right because
you know we've we've talked a little bit
I think on some previous shows about
weird animal behavior and like how they
seem to know things and stuff so you
know I'll get I'll see comments every
now and then in the comments section you
know bagging on me for being skeptical
about this stuff you know even though
things have happened to me
I'm only skeptical I'm not skeptical of
phenomenon I'm skeptical of certain
cases
yeah that's two completely different
things just because you believe one
thing doesn't mean you have to believe
all right all
this [ __ ] true no this [ __ ] can't be
true because it would contract its
contradicting itself if it is right you
know that's what I mean that's why I
thought that was kind of funny like I
kind of took the comments off cuz the
guy was kind of like but uh yeah like I
said if you say anything mildly dickish
I'm just gonna take you off it's like I
don't have time for that [ __ ] but um
yeah it seems to me because the
implication behind that is because you
had a poltergeist experience I have to
believe that you have to believe
everything yeah and that those two
things are not right I have to believe
in angels grace as described in the Old
Testament yeah the Old Testament or the
New Testament because the description is
different yeah maybe there is an angelic
type being but maybe that's a creature
that is so advanced it no it's in
another realm it no longer has to has to
incarnate anymore
would that be an angel or maybe some
kind of an elemental spirit that has a
real high mentality is that an angel you
know it all depends on what your point
of view is well I'm the thing about
yours do is that this that's one of the
things and one of the reasons why I'm
skeptical a lot of quote-unquote
paranormal stuff or new-age type of
stuff is because I'm a very logical
science minded person and if you cannot
you know definitively just define your
terms tell me what it is you are talking
about um you know you can't use this
kind of wishy-washy deepak chopra kind
of language that you know when that
sounds like it means something but when
you think about it doesn't really mean
anything yeah um you know you have to
definitively state this is what I
believe this is what I think this thing
is and then we can test that oh then we
can check that out if you're just gonna
use all these weaselly wishy-washy type
of terms you know I'm not gonna follow
you on that my eyes will start to glaze
over I'm like you're really not saying
anything of any substance yeah we live
in a rich age of science and reason you
know we know that things that exist only
exist because it's part of the natural
world well some of this stuff that I've
seen that people call supernatural or or
paranormal I've seen it so I know it's
real I don't really care if anybody else
you know I don't
leave it or not so I've seen it so I
know it's part of the natural world it's
not supernatural it's just that we don't
know what it what the natural world is
really made out of you know right I
think it's you know some of the stuff a
quantum theory you know some of the
paper from that kind of explains a lot a
lot of a lot of what I saw you know yeah
like yeah there I believe that there is
an afterlife but it may not be the
afterlife you're expecting you know I
mean it's like another dimension yeah
you know and maybe you're not there for
very long you know or you go there and
you don't really have the same identity
you have now that version of you is gone
but your point of view is over there now
and I mean and you're like a playful
little creature you don't have many
memories of your prior lives you know
that may be a possibility you know based
on certain things I said but we're kind
of getting off that off the track it's
just just because you know we don't
believe in a case doesn't necessarily
mean that we don't believe in a
phenomena right yeah yeah because you
know people could make up something
right you know what I mean
it's it's kind of like people get their
houses broken into but it's like you
know people could make up getting their
house yeah into like um I know that
poltergeist phenomena is real for a
while I believed in a case called the
South Shields poltergeist but the more I
thought about that case and the
situation around the South Shields
poltergeist the lest I believe in that
particular case doesn't mean I don't
believe in poltergeist I just don't
believe the South Shields case twas him
who was authentic yeah or at least much
of it was not authentic because maybe
they just exaggerated or added things to
that case in the same way that you know
and this house is haunted the Enfield
case not all aspects of that case were
true some because a lot had a lot of
different witnesses yeah some of the
witnesses reported things that didn't
happen yeah you know for those yeah I'm
faint so
same type of thing the same thing but
that case did happen yeah yeah okay so
let's talk a little bit about Edgar
Cayce and about his earlier life now
here's something I didn't really know
like I said I kind of know shoutout um I
really just had a couple brief ones you
know obviously a new audio book villain
to go check it out I usually put up
something real well I usually put a link
like a bounty link in the in the
description if you're not an audible
member then you can use that link and
buy it and I'll get a bounty um you can
check out our last movie review which
was don't look now with a Nicholas Rowe
a good film yeah one of my favorites in
the 1970s also I stated this on the last
week's show about Son of Sam and I also
wrote it on patron for patrons only
as I said we're changing up our
production schedule it does not affect
when the shows are gonna go up but we're
just gonna be recording more of them at
once so that I can get ahead of it so if
you are a patron of no matter what tier
you're on I'm going to start giving you
a heads up of what the topic for the
upcoming week is going to be what the
movie for the upcoming week is going to
be and I'm also probably going to start
providing like links to the show like a
day early so just so people will feel
like they're getting something and I'm
also gonna start doing as I said I do a
quarterly mail out for $20 plus patrons
I just send out t-shirts or books or
whatever I'm also gonna start doing a
quarterly drawing of people in the lower
tiers and I'm just gonna pick a random
name and if you win the drawing then
you'll get like either the same thing
the $20 patron get or maybe like a
special gift or something like that so
I'm really trying to kind of up our
participation like on the patreon page
because I know that I haven't been doing
a lot of it lately just because I
haven't had time and you know various
other things have intervened I'm also
gonna try to start putting like maybe
the little videos and [ __ ] on there so
if you're not a patron and you want to
go over there and check it out you can
like if you're already a patron
hopefully you will like the changes not
anything drastic but I'm just gonna try
and you know kind of
get more interaction going on there and
so far I've gotten good feedback on that
so hopefully you guys will enjoy it so I
think that's about it so let's see I
kind of start talking about Edgar Cayce
you know like I said I had heard of
Edgar Cayce I think I probably read some
books about him when I was a teenager
because I was kind of into all that
paranormal like poltergeist stuff and
psychic stuff and everything when I was
younger um so he's kind of known like I
said as the 20th century Nostradamus is
like the you know the greatest psychic
the greatest seer obviously the one that
has the most quote-unquote documentation
because so many of his readings were
written down yeah and these guys wrote a
lot of material yeah he didn't write it
and like assistants and like
stenographers and stuff like I'm not
sure he was fully literate was he um you
know what I think that is a
misconception because I think that
stemmed from I think it was an old old
New York Times article that said like
illiterate like has all these you know
medical you know he makes all these
medical diagnoses but he was not
illiterate that that is a misconception
actually he was quite an avid reader of
the Bible and of other books about the
occult about homeopathy about Osteopathy
various other things so he wasn't a
dummy like he only had an eighth grade
education but he was from a farm family
and that was pretty common then because
you know once you were you know kind of
in your teenage years you were old
enough to work on the farm then you quit
school and worked on the farm that's
just what they didn't need education is
anyways right as they could read write
and do the arithmetic that was all they
needed yeah so so I think that's kind of
a misconception that he was just this
country bumpkin that didn't know
anything and can you really but he could
read they usually continued to read if
there was anything to him so you know
even though they were from a farm family
some of these guys could get quite good
at what they were doing so yeah he was
just a man of his time yeah and like I
said um and one thing I didn't know even
though I knew about his you know medical
they they actually called him a
biographer called him the sleeping
prophet because all of his stuff came to
him while he was sleeping you know not
necessarily sleeping but like in a
supposed trance state altered state of
consciousness and he claimed that he had
no idea what he was saying
when he was in the trance so like when
he woke up he would read it and be like
oh and he'd be like surprised it's kind
of like automatic writing but it was
automatic speaking yeah it did seem kind
of like that like I said I don't know if
that's true I don't know if he actually
didn't remember what he said you know or
if he was just making that up
there's no way to cover everything that
this guy's done and in the scope of a
two-hour program really this guy's there
are huge libraries of stuff that you
know that was written about this guy
yeah many many books many documentaries
his foundation had whole libraries still
do still do yeah and it's kinda like if
you read Anne Rice the Edgar Cayce
foundation is a lot like the Tao of
masca if you were yeah that's like it
that's a good like that is very much
like that or it was supposedly yeah it's
also kind of before it's also kind of
like a fraternal order like the Shriners
or the Masons ya know they're their own
thing and they're you know spiritualism
kind of like spiritualism yeah I don't
think they were super heavy into seance
no that didn't seem to be a thing that
was well because um Edgar Cayce himself
was very devoutly Christian so he had a
lot of conflict within himself about
whether these psychic powers were you
know legit or Earth they were from a
godly source I guess was happening kind
of would have termed it and he also like
had some stuff about when he started to
accept like reincarnation and things
like that which a lot of the church
group that he belonged to did not like
that because they thought that was
unchristian and they you know so he kind
of gotten a little bit of hot water
there from what I know of him my take on
what he was doing it was a situation
kind of like self-hypnosis yeah and kind
of like accessing the quantum record or
like the Akash all that the Akashic
record he did call pulling information
or knowledge from the universe something
very similar to kind of like remote
viewing an astral projection yes it was
and it was an ability like that because
he acts
termed he you know when he was asked to
specify like where he was getting this
information from he either said like you
said it was from the Akashic record or
that he was pulling it from the
subconscious of the person for whom he
was doing the reading yeah which you
know Hameroff and Penrose might have
might have a an alternate explanation of
what that is
yeah I mean like somebody's quantum soul
for quantum consciousness interfacing
with someone else's quantum
consciousness because there's an in
quantum entanglement yeah and in the
universe - yeah so you know but yeah so
Prem bro says about it another thing -
that I did that I didn't actually know
about him was that he was kind of ahead
of the curve on this whole whole
holistic health type of thing where it's
like you know eating right and like acid
alkaline diets and all that kind of
stuff that's kind of a big trendy woowoo
think kind of now but back then it was
kind of ahead of its time and he was
kind of like the first person who's you
know say well they lead yeah we talked
about that in the Senate yeah Senna's am
Joe but that was probably why everybody
was like crazy murderous because they
were all just like blood particles
everywhere so okay so edgar cayce was
actually born in 1877 and a really
really small like rural town in Kentucky
as I said his parents were farmers
you know they had livestock wheat corn
tobacco like he usually did in Kentucky
um and from an early age I guess he was
seen as something of an odd child or at
least according to his biographer they
said that he said that he talked to
little folk which I assume were like
fairies or what-have-you
um he apparently talked to his dead
grandfather now one of the documentaries
I saw the Wikipedia page did not say
this but one of the documentaries I saw
said that Edgar Cayce had actually seen
his grandfather get killed by getting
thrown from a horse and then drowning in
a pond on the property
um and that henceforth he had been able
to talk you know speak to the ghost of
his grandfather you know from that time
but some of the other sources I read
didn't see that but all of
said that that was one of his early
experiences that he claimed he had been
able to talk to his dead grandfather and
all these like little people and stuff
like that um so when he got a little bit
older you know when he's like preteen or
something like that he got super into
religion he got super into the Bible
like I said he was not illiterate you
know he would he would read the Bible
all the time he was like very into it
and he started actually when he was a
teenager he started teaching Sunday
School like at his regular church so he
was kind of like really really engrossed
in the whole biblical Christian thing
now evidently when he was about 12 years
old so the story goes he was reading the
Bible out and his little thing in the
woods his little house or a little Hut
or whatever he had out there and a woman
with wings presumably an angel appeared
to him and said that she said I've
answered your prayers you know what do
you want more than anything else in the
world and reportedly Edgar Cayce said I
want to help people that was his wish he
he wanted to particularly help sick
children but he's like he wanted to be a
missionary so the angel presumably was
like can do so right now again the story
goes the day after this happened Edgar
Cayce was apparently he described
himself as a quote-unquote dull student
he said he was never a very good student
he was like not not stupid but he didn't
really care about his studies he was
always like too busy talking to his dead
grandpa what have you been like talking
to little people so he didn't really
care about learning anything so his dad
was always kind of like why is Oh Dom I
don't know that was like kind of you
know beating the crap out of it it's
like so this one night after this angel
appears evidently he's studying his
spelling and you know his dad is like
why are you you know you're not doing it
right and blah blah blah and the angel
comes to Edgar Cayce and says hey if you
have a sleep on this we're gonna help
you out so then ger Casey falls asleep
on the spelling-book and when he wakes
up you know
all the answers now this story comes
from K seem somewhere it comes from his
followers um this was in as far as I
know it comes from his biographer okay
so it may have come from him directly
I'm not entirely sure about that yeah um
this is just probably one of the most
widely circulated stories about him was
that he said that when he would sleep on
a book you could see all of it like it
is Alec he had a photographic memory of
it but he had to sleep on it yeah we
woke up in the morning he knew that
everything was and he knew everything
that was in the book so that's probably
one of the more famous stories about him
whether or not he was actually tested on
this probably he's probably never really
tested on right and like I said you know
the biography says you know Oh from that
point forward like you know his teachers
all said oh he was the best student we
had even though he was kind of a
mediocre student I have a feeling with
this story right here that this is kind
of a story that followers you know I
mean and students of his would tell him
it does sound like that same way
Scientologists tell stories about I'm
sure it sounds like that
that's what I was thinking it does sound
like a very like miraculous yeah you
know what I mean it's almost like one of
those weird stories about like Jesus
when he was a kid and he did all this
like amazing right you know there's a
chance that case he never really said
this or he mentioned it just told us the
tale and they kept repeating it over and
over you that's kind of what I've that's
yeah I feel good me that's kind of what
this is now apparently his ability to
diagnose medical illnesses and various
types in his sleep did not come about
until he was a teenager about 16 years
old I believe he was now it actually
first happened to him he was like
playing a game at school or whatever and
he got hit by a ball in the spine and
apparently after that he started
quote-unquote behaving strangely he goes
to sleep and while he's asleep he says
what the cure is for whatever this is
that ailed him so the family says okay
so they prepare the cure which I assume
was some kind
Herbal or folk medicine which most of
his cures were and evidently would then
when he woke up he was totally fine yeah
you know what I'm now seeing it l ron
Hubbard copied a lot of Edgar Cayce
healed his own imaginary right illnesses
his own imaginary battle scars yeah
remember that yeah so he probably got
that from Casey yeah whether or not
Casey did it or not
probably no witnesses just just uh the
legend this is the legend yeah that's
why I said the story goes because this
is like the the very common legend
that's told about Edgar Casey's early
life and they sound like the legends
that surround a religious figure yeah
and you know that from a very early age
really they were special right you know
they could do this that and the other
thing it was super amazing and everyone
said it was super amazing technically
you could call Casey a cult leader he
wasn't a malignant one one though but he
was like a cult leader yeah now
evidently even though this ability
purportedly did not reveal itself until
he was in his teenage years again when
it was his own illness or his own injury
that he was supposedly curing um it
didn't happen again until he was in his
20s so there was like some gap or they
didn't really know what's going on so
after this point like I said they you
know they had they lived in this like
little rural town later they moved to
like a slightly bigger town called
Hopkinsville and lived there that was
kind of when Casey finished his
education and dropped out of school um
so like I said and that was not unusual
for the time because he was just working
on his family's farm but it's just it's
the kind of thing where pretty much the
rest of his life he would just be
constantly struggling for money even
though he supposedly had this great
talent and a lot of people tried to
exploit it but he does seem to have had
at least according to all the accounts
he does seem to have had like some
of integrity about it or he said it
doesn't work when I'm just doing it for
profit you know what I mean yeah so I
can kind of relate to that it's almost
kind of like it's faith-based yeah in
other words if you're doing it for
someone else it helps your faith and
helps you to manifest the these effects
yeah if you're doing it for profit you
don't feel good about it and you can't
manifest it yeah yes he's claiming he's
quiet yeah so maybe most and it does
seem to be that in later years when he
was doing AB readings for people and
some people when he was in a trance and
like I said he said that he didn't
remember what he was what he was talking
about or anything like that and would
ask him things like hey what's the
outcome of this horse race gonna be or
smelly so they could gamble on it he
would give you an answer but it wouldn't
necessarily be the right one right you
know what I mean so um he said that if
you know if it wasn't done specifically
to help people then he couldn't verify
like the accuracy of it yes so it's not
like it didn't work it's just that he
might give you a wrong answer I don't
know if he was whatever his ass or from
what I remember about Edgar Cayce all
the readings I did about him
he was according to witnesses very good
with medicine yeah that's what I
remember about it according to the
witnesses he would tell you how to heal
yourself and what to drink and what to
eat yeah and it would go what your
problems would go away according to
these witnesses right and that's kind of
a problem I have it like I'm not saying
that all of this is [ __ ] but I do
want to point out that a lot of this
stuff about him and about his like
quote-unquote miraculous cures and stuff
like that is all anecdotal yeah you
can't prove it or disprove it and pretty
much yes a lot of it was recorded you
know because it was you know everything
he said was written down by like
stenographers and assistants and whatnot
but you don't know like a lot of the
cases that are like in his library and
stuff like that there's no follow-up
it's like did these people actually do
that and it cured them did they die yeah
we did they died because there was some
things later like like he would get a
letter that said hey
can you heal my this and that and by the
time he got to the letter cuz he got so
many by the time he got to letter that
person was dead but he didn't know that
you know what I mean which you think he
would know if he was actually saying
yeah and another thing is that placebo
is a real effect it is so if you believe
strongly enough that something will work
it will work right so this case he
actually just kind of given placebos to
people that do work or is you know we
don't know yeah and like I said most of
his stuff was like folk remedies only
simpler long-dead you can't you can't
talk to him you can't a woman do yeah
nothing difficult it's difficult to do a
true investigation because my you might
get the people's names but you don't
know if these people really existed you
don't have the social security number
the you know the address yeah and the
thing true is that when they you know
when they did all these people they
would take the person's name and they
would black it out and they would give
her one a number before they put it in
the library
hmm you know what I mean so they do have
all the original letters that were sent
to him there but yeah but they blacked
out everyone's name because for privacy
concerns I would imagine you know or
they don't want people to judge right I
don't know if I wanna I'm not gonna go
there because I don't think that I don't
think he necessarily I don't think he
had any nefarious intent at all I'm not
saying that other people around him did
not um but he does not seem to have had
any kind of the didn't seem to be any
any motive for financial gain yeah like
I said other people around him did try
to cash in but he never really seemed to
so I I I don't want to like attribute
any nefarious motivations to him in
particular because I don't think he had
any now he did have kind of a cult
following of a bunch of people around
him he did yeah
all right man we don't know how honest
they were that's what I'm saying that's
so I'm just saying I'm not [ __ ] on
that guy it's like but some of the
people around him might have been
shysters and they were trying to make a
buck on the site or make off of him
maybe even write fake books in his name
to try to sell there's no
way of knowing and maybe the fact that
he was such a nice person it was easy to
go to get over on him maybe right that's
what I mean it right out there this is
yeah so okay so like I said you know at
this point he's in Hopkinsville Kentucky
he actually got engaged to Gertrude who
was like the love of his life they were
married until they both died he was a
very active church member like I said he
taught Sunday School he did he trained
missionaries needed all that kind of
stuff and as I said because he was such
a devout Christian he had a lot of I
mean at first he had a lot of problems
with this supposed psychic ability that
he had because he didn't know if he was
supposed to be doing it you know I mean
because there's that whole biblical
admonition about yeah is he is he
cheating is he going against God yes so
this seems to be like a conflict that
really kind of you know he was it was
really something that was on his mind a
lot it seems like what could technically
be something kind of like alchemy or or
witchcraft and that would be a sin right
so probably weren't worried whether or
not he's committing
yeah he did seem to be and like I said
in later years you know some people that
members of his church where he taught
Sunday School and stuff like that
actually absolutely did think that and
they thought that oh it's from the devil
or it's witchcraft or whatever and they
didn't want him teaching their kids at
Sunday School and stuff like that so
there was that whole thing so around
1900 Agra Casey and his dad they put
together this company they were gonna
sell insurance now shortly after this
happened
edgar cayce gets this really really bad
case of most sources say that it was
laryngitis and mostly lost his voice now
if you're an insurance salesman you kind
of need to be able to talk and he could
not so at this point he kind of had to
move back in like I think the business
ended up failing in the end but he had a
movement back in with his parents and
he's like okay well I need some work
that doesn't entail me talking so much
so he actually went to apprentice with a
photographer
a photography studio and this is
actually something that he ended up
doing for most of the rest of his life
like he would open his own photography
studios and stuff like that that was
kind of his main source of income was
doing photography work because he
actually got quite good at it
and if you seem like any of the photos
that he took of his wife or like they're
actually really really nice so there was
that whole thing big business that's
what my grandfather did yeah yeah
high-tech [ __ ] back in those days well
yeah I mean it was like super expensive
too because it's like you know it's not
like now we're just like yeah but yeah
so he started doing that now the
following year he met this stage
hypnotist magician type of thing who's
called the laughs man mr. Hart and he
had heard about Edgar Cayce not being
able to talk I think he could still talk
but you could barely hear it it was like
very very raspy and he kind of like was
like oh well I guess my voice is [ __ ]
up forever it's like I can't talk
anymore
so this hypnotist hears about it and he
says well maybe if I hypnotize you and
give you a posthypnotic suggestion that
you get your voice back you know maybe
that will work or maybe hypnosis won't
work so he actually hypnotized Edgar
Cayce and allegedly when he was in the
trance he could talk normally but then
when he woke up again
his voice was all [ __ ] up again now
because mr. Hart the laughs man said
that well you know I have to go on to
the next city I have time for this to do
this but he's like I think the reason
that it didn't work was because you
didn't go all the way down into hypnosis
you were like fighting it or whatever so
he suggested these other hypnotists that
he go to so he starts going to other
hypnotist and trying to figure it out
but then he meets this guy who is like
an osteopath or hypnotist type dude
named Lane dr. Lane I guess I don't know
if he was an actual medical doctor or
not he was one of those kind of you know
kind of questionable kind of doctors Oh
so he's like uh he's like I think what
you should do is you should hypnotize
yourself and then it will cure you
really like as if someone else is doing
it it's not working evidently so
hypnosis and mesmerism was like a big
thing yeah and actually yeah that they
even mentioned that like on a lot of
sources that franz mesmer that was like
a big thing and you know there's a lot
of that [ __ ] we're sure about you the
powers of the mind [ __ ] right exactly so
evidently this this session or this
series of sessions where he was able to
go into this trance or self hypnosis he
diagnosed his own ailment and was able
to cure himself now it wasn't like
immediate they said that he did have
some relapses like you know you're a
couple years in the future and it would
come and go but that overall it did end
up working so after this presumed like
self hypnosis cure and stuff like that
dr. Lane you know who was kind of
interested in franz mesmer and all those
other types of people said you know
Edgar Cayce you should take this on the
road you know maybe other people can
benefit from you going into a trance and
like you know diagnosing their illnesses
and you know prescribing a cure or
whatever now Edgar Cayce was initially
quite reluctant because he said you know
I don't know what I'm saying
when I'm asleep and he's like all it
would take is for me to say something
[ __ ] up while I'm asleep and somebody
does that and then they die and then I'm
a murderer
he's like Suze I don't know anything
about medicine or so he said
you know so I don't know what I'm
prescribing you know somebody could be
taking him be poisonous I don't really
know what I'm doing so he didn't want to
take it on for that and his wife
Gertrude actually agreed but he was able
to be convinced that he ought to do it
now as I said he very famously learned
very quickly very early on that he did
not even have to be in the same room
with a person all he needed was like
their name and where they were and he
could supposedly go into a particular
trance and he would know what was
the matter with this person I think he
had to be done I think he had another
symptom though well well actually no I
was all he said
because he said he didn't want to know
about them okay ahead of time at least
that's what most of the sources I said
said I read said that he all he needed
to know was their name and where they
were at the time of the reading okay
yeah I mean I don't know because I'm
sure that some of the letters that they
got like probably described what the
problem was which in some cases you know
that wouldn't be quite as impressive if
you just read the letter and though yeah
you've got X Y Z whatever I also didn't
know that he claimed not yeah that's
what he claimed but like I said I kind
of dispute that because cuz I couldn't
remember some of the things some of the
advice that he gave a long time ago I
don't I don't remember the particulars
but I remember thinking boy how did he
know that you know he yeah because some
of the stuff seemed to have been like a
good remedy for that problem yeah I mean
right well I remember thinking that but
I can't give you an exam that's the
thing and like I said most of the stuff
he prescribed was pretty common folk
remedies that were pretty well known at
the time and I think even though he said
that he didn't know anything about
medicine he did hang out with a lot of
doctors a lot of osteopaths a lot of
people who were in that line of work
particularly like you know nature
healing type of stuff he write a lot of
books about that he read it with key
read like a lot of like Madame Blavatsky
and well they're you know people like
that so it's not quite as amazing as it
sounds like he wasn't a dummy like I
said he knew this stuff right I got a
feeling he had medical knowledge I think
he might have or at least he picked some
up yeah from people he knew or things
that he read that's still kind of the
same as having medical knowledge though
yeah he had medical knowledge I believe
because a lot of the you know I read
some of his readings of people and like
of their illnesses and the cures and
stuff like that and some of it one is
kind of vague like a lot of psychic [ __ ]
is and a lot of it even when he did say
something specific it sounded like
something
he had you know remembered from a book I
remembered from like one of his
osteopath friends saying it or something
like that I seem to remember this is a
long time ago I mean I may be wrong but
I seem to remember him town Sun T
telling somebody to drink like a little
bit of iodine in some water and yeah I
don't remember what it was I remember
thinking at the time goes yeah that's
probably an iodine deficiency yeah
talking about and like I said I'm not
real sure if you know how and I'm not
real sure like when people wrote to him
because most people that he did readings
for had written to him for help and they
might have described yeah don't hold me
to that there's things about somebody
else it's been a long time since I've
actually so like I said it might not be
as amazing as it sounds because it's
like he might have had prior knowledge
and then maybe I'm not saying he didn't
go into trances and stuff but maybe in a
trance or in an unconscious or altered
state he could kind of remember like all
these bits and pieces of information
that he had picked up over the years and
was able to like cobble them together
into something that seemed like to
legitimately how the person you know I
mean so I don't know if it was
necessarily psychic maybe he was just
very intuitive when I was young you know
I read a lot of bottom and I don't
remember ever coming away with any kind
of negativity associated with the guy I
thought he was a good guy he seems like
a very very nice man so and honestly um
he he and Gertrude actually had three
sons one of them died when he was only
two months old which a lot of skeptics
will point out he did a reading on that
kid but it didn't save the kid but two
of his sons survived into adulthood and
they later went on to you know do his
foundation and everything like that I
think they both passed away now but they
were as far as I know both of them were
interviewed for some of the
documentaries I saw and they also seemed
like very nice people and you know and
they had nothing but nice things to say
about him interestingly his two sons
when they were older they published a
book about him that I think was called
like the limits of Edgar Casey's power
or something like that in that book they
claimed that he had an 85 percent
success rate but in this book
interestingly they concentrated on the
quote unquote 15 percent of cases where
he was wrong so I thought that was kind
of an interesting
yeah okay so they weren't like I said I
got no impression that edgar cayce
himself was a charlatan or that he was
like a bullshitter or anything like that
I'm not it wasn't an LRH it wasn't that
Elrond hug right he wasn't like trying
to like you know right like you know
inflate himself into being anything he
seemed very humble he did seem to
genuinely want to help people and he did
seem to believe that he was actually
helping people whether the people around
him were taking advantage or we're
trying to you know ride yeah something
bigger than he was you know that's
another question but I don't think I
never got the impression that he was any
kind of crook or any kind of power I
remember what stands out what I remember
about the guy what I thought was cool
back in this day was all the little
stories and predictions he made about
ancient Egypt the Sphinx the pyramids
and all that stuff about Atlantis yeah
he talked a lot about it yes it was you
know I I haven't heard it in a long time
it's just from memory my memory says
that it was [ __ ] yeah but it was
pretty cool [ __ ] about the Atlantis
well appending to you and the thing is
is that me what maybe he's talking about
something else yeah yeah I mean maybe
he's talking about cuz I remember he was
given some locations where he was saying
what parts of Atlantis were and if I
remember correctly later on they did
find some artifacts or things that look
like artifacts underneath the sea in
that area but it was I think it was a
natural formation though it looked like
a road yeah did you come across that no
but honestly from what I've read I
believe that he perceived Atlantis to be
not just like some dinky as little
island he perceived to be like a Content
continent that it was like and it was in
the Atlantic yes I don't like that other
guy he thought that Atlantis may have
been Antarctica when Antarctica was
closer to the equator yeah that that
might have been that it kind of fits
that what's his name he's the guy that
writes all the the books about ancient
Egypt and everything he's got into the
big ayahuasca thing so he's doing TED
talk
[ __ ] I do but I can't he had he wrote
some wild books to my favorite
prediction that Edgar Cayce made about
Atlantis was that I believe he said it
would be in 1958
maybe 1968 that we would discover an
Atlantean Death Ray lantee and Efrain 58
did that happen who knows maybe maybe
they're covering it up maybe he's
talking about some of the radio wave
weapons that the United maybe Union
we're trying to figure out you're good
massage ultrasound it's kind of like a
death ray yeah ultrasound microwaves
yeah you know I do don't know but the
the Japanese were working on a microwave
weapon back in World War two yeah yeah
they were actually bombarding people
monkeys and evidently had this some of
surmised POWs with a bunch of microwaves
to cook them to see if they could do it
and they were gonna put this thing on a
down track the vehicle and send it out
to the coastline just microwave incoming
American ships during the invasion
you'll see this weapon in the Godzilla
movies another tank with the bent with
the damn tube with the radar dish on the
end of it yeah that is the microwave
weapon they were trying to build in
World War two yeah whoo yeah cook you
like a hot pot yeah yeah
in the Godzilla movies it's shooting a
lightning bolt but that's that's the
microwave weapon they were trying to
work they were trying to build in World
War two I'm gonna blow you up just like
all the old urban legends about yeah
yeah all right so let's take a break
right now and then we come back we will
talk more about Edgar Cayce and about
his prophecies and also kind of go maybe
in a little bit of the skeptical type of
thing because I read a lot about that
too so we will be back in just a few the
faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century volume 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
Massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom
the slaughter of dozens of women and
girls along the highway of tears and the
Texas killing fields and the mysterious
death of suspected spy the is doll woman
along with dozens of other fascinating
and horrifying accounts by it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format oh look it's all full there's
treats in their paws
yeah can you get them can you get them I
know who can get him I've seen you do it
if there's treats involved you're gonna
be all about it you're gonna get them oh
good girl good girl you're a genius
yes you are you're a genius why are you
chuckling it though why are you choking
it yeah I know you got your treat that's
super good right there don't you they're
more of them in there she likes to eat
them with her hands for some reason
she's very dainty
okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the wig out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making jetty
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put a spotlight on ourselves
and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves
if you go ahead and pick up on these
shirts today you guys are gonna love
them mix in the description WWL calm at
13 o'clock yes ago check out our store
at wwl calm slash 13 o'clock we got
these four cool new t-shirt designs plus
all our old ones if you'd rather get one
of the old ones but these ones are
awesome and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cut
they look really cute JT's got some so
thank you go check them out
okay we're back talking about edgar
cayce the sleeping prophet yeah now at
this stage he actually moved to Bowling
Green Kentucky and there were some
doctors that were kind of like
sympathetic to his cause and they kind
of wanted to figure out what it was that
he was doing so they wanted to do you
know not like experiment on him like cut
him open like a lab rat but like you
know kind of watch him under some more
controlled conditions see if there's
anything to him to see that there is
anything to it now evidently by all
accounts these quote-unquote experiments
did not go well and Edgar Cayce said
that I'm not gonna do that [ __ ] anymore
so that was that whole thing he didn't
want to be I guess poked and prodded or
experimented upon he just wanted to do
his [ __ ] in peace or whatever nothing
survives about what exactly they did to
him or anything not really like not that
I know of all right now he actually had
opened up a photographic studio this one
the first one burned down and then he
opened another one and that one burned
down also it was like a year apart and
this ended up bankrupting him now his
friend there was this guy named Wesley
Ketchum who was a homeopath and he's
trying to talk Edgar Cayce into like
taking money for his readings because he
never has or at least like opening some
type of institution or some type of
hospital or something like that to help
people and start charging people because
like I said you know at this point
KC and his family were broke because his
photographic studios have burned down
but Edgar Cayce still did not like to
take money for his readings and like I
said I I feel like it was probably
because one I think he felt weird about
having this gift like I said because he
was kind of like a hardcore Christian
and he didn't know if it was like you
know if it was a sin copacetic or not um
also I think like I said I think when he
did things for financial reasons I think
he felt like the accuracy wasn't as good
or it wasn't as helpful so he would
always like refused so he always like
tried to find some like workarounds so
what they actually ended up doing was
that Ketchum said okay well we'll
start a company but what we're gonna do
instead of giving you money for the
readings directly I'll just you know
we'll pay for you to have a photography
studio and you can make your money doing
that but then like we'll use the money
in you than the reading scam and so you
still get money but you're not getting
money for that okay you know what I mean
they would go through the back channel
they're gonna laundry money yeah there
we go I feel like there was a lot of
that going on like particularly in the
later like when he opened like his
hospital and he opened his Institute
like it would be a kind of thing where
he didn't like I said he didn't like to
take money for the readings directly so
what he would do he's like oh well if
you come to the center you pay for a
membership right and then you can get
readings and you get access to all these
other things but you know the the
membership money would go back into the
foundation or whatever so there was that
whole thing it's a fair way to do it
right that was you know fair enough it's
like he wouldn't take money directly you
know ever as far as next up in the
psychic forces could now flip I guess
but like I said now some doc out here in
the men's room and you're trying to go
you try to pee his neck to you you not i
mean you putting you under pressure yeah
now well the same thing happens to women
is what why baby cooking yeah would you
say anything she's just like try to move
the camera like she's like okay she's
just laying down behind a laptop she's
being a good girl you be a good girl
okay
yeah well women have the same thing it's
like you know I don't I don't like going
to pee in a public bathroom and there's
like a bunch of people like on either
side I'm just like I don't know I feel
weird about it I wish they would put
more noise yeah you know what I mean
yeah based on my experiences these
paranormal effects if you want to call
them psychic abilities I think I don't
like that term yeah these these
paranormal occurrences are kind of like
that yeah if you scrutinize it too much
it won't happen yeah and you got to be
relaxed yeah and you know the army even
thought the same thing with improv and
project was called Project Star Gate one
of the end results of that whole project
was is that that they didn't say they
said basically you know to paraphrase if
they say we're not going to call
[ __ ] on psychic
abilities but we know that they don't
work under the stress at war of warfare
and they don't work in combat because
you can't do it on command yeah reliably
well actually under stress like I said
it's too unreliable yeah it's nothing
that could be counted that's that's that
was the Army's take away now here's a
weird thing they're doing something
still kind of like a little bit kind of
like psychic abilities they had a
training program where they would send
guys through a virtual reality situation
and some guys would get a bad feeling
with the images that they were showing
that they were walking into an ambush
and some guys were better at predicting
an ambush than others even though they
were just seeing pre-recorded video
right that's weird
some people have better intuition than
others like I said it's just like any
other ability and so in the army
couldn't explain why because the video
content of a situation dead was gonna
have an ambush initiated and one that
wasn't was equal right there was there
were no visual giveaways right and and
they noticed that some guys could had a
had a better ability to predict when the
video would show an ambush yeah and they
put those guys as front men well as he
would yeah and yeah so I feel like
something like that Special Forces oh
yeah because it does seem like you know
like I said and they have this even in
like in sports and everything like that
if you start like overthinking things
thinking about how all the ways you
could mess it up right you need to I
mean even like athletes and stuff talk
about being in the zone that means
you're like not thinking about it you're
just doing [ __ ] without thinking about
automatic and that's when you do your
best [ __ ] when you're thinking because
and evidently think it's good but it
gets you in trouble
evidently the army knew about this too
and a lot of their elite guys in Special
Forces and then they're you know I've
made a little Delta teams and stuff
some of those guys went through some
training like that yeah weird they
talked about that also and remember that
series that we watched the dead zone
yeah where yeah Johnny's helping
military intelligence that was based on
project Stargate fine tear yes
there was one or two episodes like that
where yes like helping them out it's
based on something that really did
happen the TV series nothing good but
yeah so that's the thing too is that so
like I said there was they had one son
who lived they had another son like in
the middle name Milton and he died he
was only two months old now like I said
a lot of skeptics have pointed out you
know oh why couldn't he save the baby
um you know I've seen different sources
about that some said oh maybe he was
like reluctant to like do reading on his
own baby or whatever but the baby died
now shortly after that his wife Gertrude
got tuberculosis and allegedly the
doctor said yeah she's gonna die she's
got like a week to live and she
supposedly now Gertrude she was a
supportive wife they clearly loved each
other very much um but she seemed a
little reticent about the whole psychic
key thing like she did help him out like
in later years you know she would do the
readings and would write stuff down for
him and stuff but she doesn't seem to
been super jazzed about it um but she
did ask him when she was apparently
dying to do a reading and supposedly she
was cured even though the doctor said
she was gonna die and had quote-unquote
given up on her hmm
apparently he did a reading Oh like I
said I don't know how true that is but
that's like what all the sources say
that she was they said she was going to
die but she ended up not dying of
tuberculosis she actually outlived him
by a few months so at this point like I
said constantly short of money he's at
this point asking for donations and
stuff to continue his work he actually
also invented a card game which I
believe is still sold even though I had
never heard of it's called pit it's a he
did it like a week trading type of thing
it's like a card game I'm not sure how
you play it but everything I read said
yeah they still sell it or they still
sell some form of it so he's apparently
the one that invented that I don't know
how much money he got from it but he did
invent that that's still around so at
this stage he gets in the papers he's
like there's
there was like a very popular magazine
that wrote like a big thing about him
and so this is kind of when [ __ ] started
pouring in like around the world you
know people were writing to him from far
away because they've here's the guy that
can like just carry you from a letter
and he'll tell you like he became a
living legend pretty much yeah
now at first he was only doing two
readings a day he said each reading took
about 45 minutes because he said you
know it took a lot out of him I guess it
was very psychically or you know
mentally straining um the sad thing was
later in his life he felt so bad that
like the letters were getting backed up
and everything like that that he went up
to like eight readings a day and they
think that that's eventually what killed
him was just like overwork but you know
now one thing like I said at this stage
he had mostly been doing like medical
diagnoses like people were writing him
like I have this illness blah blah but
then in the 1920s like early 1920s um he
had a friend named Arthur Lammers who
was kind of in a metaphysics and stuff
and started asking him about you know
bigger questions about human
consciousness what are we doing here you
know what is God what's the nature of
God and stuff like that and so Edgar
Cayce started going more in that sort of
metaphysical direction even though like
I said I don't think he really meant to
but if he was under if he was in his
trance and somebody asked him about that
stuff he would apparently give a long
detailed answer that you know his
stenographer whoever would write down
and then he would read it afterward and
be surprised what the [ __ ] I said all
that okay you know what I mean and I
think I found a quote from him he's like
I said all that I couldn't have said all
that in one reading that was like a
quote from him so his friend Lammers was
like you know I've been studying
metaphysics for years but what you just
said when you were in the trance that's
totally sounds legit he basically said
stuff like because like I said he was
very into you know Christianity so he
was very in like anti reincarnation he
didn't like want to know anything about
it but you know he eventually kind of
came to the thing where all religions
are
or they're all like seeking the same
thing so if it gets you closer to that
then it's okay you know what I mean so
he kind of like opened up to like
everyone is pursuing the same thing even
if it's like you know Buddhism or it's
Christian Dior's but you know it's all
good as long as you're getting to the
same place like you're just trying to be
a better person you're all in the same
genre right you're trying to you know
just get to a greater spiritual
awareness which you know there's nothing
wrong with that that's kind of that's a
nice message so he kind of eventually
got to that got to that place so that's
New Age that's and that's what I mean
that that's why he's sometimes called
like the father of New Age or the father
of like holistic medicine I've seen him
called that too because like I said he
was one of the first to advocate this
whole mind-body you know everything is
one and we all need like what you put in
your body and it like makes a big
difference at all which which actually
checks out with a lot of my experiences
yeah my the big mind-body link yeah
everything he's saying ya know are there
something to that yeah now one thing
that he had always wanted to do was as I
said his primary goal seemed to have
been or so he said that he wanted to
help people he wanted to open a hospital
where he would diagnose people but there
would be actually medical professionals
there that would like you know do the
cures that he was you know advocating
for so he had been trying to do that for
quite a long time
you know they started at various
foundations where people would you know
interested people would give them money
that and news later a lot kind of stuff
so they did actually have enough money
to open a hospital problem was that in
one of his trances they had actually
wanted him I believe they at first
wanted him to open the hospital in
Dayton Ohio
or maybe Selma Alabama I can't really
remember but because he lived in both of
those places but for some reason one of
his vision said no you have to open it
in Virginia Beach Virginia which was at
the time kind of a small it's like a
resort town like not a lot of people
lived there he wanted to go there
because he thought
the ocean was you know helped with his
abilities and also that the sand was
like curative somehow he was kind of one
of this is kind of why I'm always kind
of like skeptical this type of stuff
because as much good [ __ ] as they say
like yeah you shouldn't smoke so much
and he did say things like you know
everything in moderation and blah blah
which is like normal reasonable that
wasn't right and you know he said
reasonable things but then he would also
say below healing crystals and kind of
like you know it you could have just
stayed right here but then you had to go
over there you know so yeah I never
bought into the crystals thing right so
he it seems like he did kind of because
some of the cures that he advocated
farmer work gemstones I remember
correctly a lot of his Atlantis visions
yeah do with them using crystalline
technology yeah yeah you did like a
giant solar crystal that ice yeah right
he was claiming to see the past in these
visions and seeing Atlantis and all this
weird Atlantean technology yeah um I
gotta say it's it's it's straight out of
1800 science fiction yeah it's straight
out of that which I would think that
it's highly unlikely some of the things
that he said about ancient egypt sound a
little bit more likely and a couple of
them actually turned out to be true
there is something underneath the paw of
the Sphinx right whether it's like some
Atlantean library or the Akashic record
or whatever has yet to be determined I
think he said there were a couple other
chambers inside the Great Pyramid that
are yet to be discovered and he said
that's not a crazy thing to say a big
[ __ ] pyramid that's coming that's
starting to come true yeah they're
pretty sure there's some pretty big
chambers and they're undiscovered still
using like you some kind of radar
there's some empty spaces in there but
I'd be cool to see what's in there yeah
I think there's these air shafts yeah
going through it you know weird but yeah
so that's the thing they actually did
get um I don't believe he personally had
the money to buy
particularly in what was then not a very
popular resort town Virginia Beach but
one of his supporters who I think was a
stockbroker he actually ended up buying
them a house there and actually Virginia
Beach is where their world headquarters
still is to this day that's where their
their Institute is I think they have
another one might be in Houston I want
to say Houston Texas maybe Austin I
cameras somewhere in Texas but their
main one is still in Virginia Beach you
know still so like I said his remedies
for stuff even though he had all these
other doctors supposedly on staff at
this hospital were very focus in he you
know what I mean it was just be like hey
take a rabbit and turn it inside out and
put the blood side like on where your
cancer is and so you know his stuff like
that
yeah so some of it was probably fine and
harmless like you know a mud bath isn't
gonna hurt anybody you know not smoking
so much is gonna hurt anybody
but some of this stuff was a little
quacky sounding I have to say crystals
and all that yeah yeah so there was a
lot of that kind of stuff and some of it
was probably actively harmful yeah like
what well I'm just saying like stuff
like you know drink some ammonia you
know things you know [ __ ] like that yeah
we're I don't know if he actually said
that in anything but I'm just saying for
an example you know stuff that's
probably not all that good for you it's
like hey this will kill your cancer if
you [ __ ] drink bleach I know an old
guy who's an old gunsmith machinist he
used to drink
hydrogen peroxide I've heard of people
that did it put it in water not cure and
he just said aw it helps you it helps
your respiration and I don't know if
that was just an old person thing maybe
that was from that could have been from
something like Edgar Cayce maybe yeah
now see I've never heard of any big
drinking it but when I was growing up my
grandparents and my dad would gargle
with it okay
know this old guys I know that helped I
used to clean my ears out with it he'd
pour a glass he'd pour a big old glass
like that and maybe about 1/4 of it was
hydrogen peroxide yeah and he would also
like do things like take a glass and
then drop a couple drops of iodine in it
you know and you know what he lived a
long time died in his sleep - Jim graves
although like I said I'm always kind of
like medical [ __ ] man it's just so it's
really hard because there's a lot of
[ __ ] that you can do to your body that
will not probably not hurt you at least
in the short run and actually by the
time it does something bad to you it
might be so long ago that you don't even
remember that [ __ ] happening to you or
you don't remember doing it you don't
remember that being harmful but there's
there's a really lot of particularly
where medical [ __ ] is concerned there's
a lot of Oh while I was sick and I did
this particular thing and then I got
better but you didn't necessarily get
better because of that particular thing
you might have gotten better from like a
lot of different things maybe it just
went away on its own maybe it was
something else that you did maybe you
know I mean but I people have a tendency
to and this is why I like ever every I
took several psychology classes and
understanding my psychology professor
was very big on correlation is not
causation just because something
happened after something else that
doesn't mean that that caused that yeah
he's like and that's but that's a very
common thing for human brains to do it's
like oh I had a cold and then I ate a
cup of chicken soup and the next day it
was gone so the chicken soup cures a
cold well Big Jim said that the hydrogen
peroxide helped oxygen get into your red
blood cells they told me he said he
after that's some good shabbos it's
bubbly I don't know it was it was like
Big Jim knew my grandfather my
grandfather almost raised him back in
the day yeah he just was a big and he
was kind of a strange guy big machinist
and you know ya worked on guns for the
police department yeah yeah yeah
drank hydrogen peroxide that's not been
sober like I've gargled with it a couple
of times cuz it's supposed to you know
it's kills germs and stuff so I guess
it's not gonna kill you if you just
gargle with then spit it out yeah but
honestly I couldn't even do it for that
long because it tastes so yucky that
iodine and also I have all those cures
yeah I once saw him burn a wart off of
his thumb using some kind of acid
McCarrick acid oh yeah yeah I started
snapping and popping and I was going god
damn it's just like until they goddamn
always hurt now that's it What's in
compound W I wonder does that that's the
acid he had all kinds of strange poisons
in there he had our snick and cyanide
and stuff things used for blue in guns
and weird craft like that you can kill
yourself at his shop I did it careful ID
I kind of feel like here's the thing
like so there's so much of like the past
everything was poisonous yeah people
would put anything in their [ __ ]
bodies were they doing thinking about it
I mean even the makeup that women use
cuz they wanted to look paler because
you know if you had a suntan that it
looked like he worked in a field near
were poor so nobody wanted that so
people would like put [ __ ] on their
faces like to make their faces paler I
read about this and I don't know if you
guys know about and I should do a show
about this because I'm so fascinated by
this the subject of the very famous John
Singer Sargent Sargent painting madam X
and that was something that she did she
was very known for her beauty and for
her very very pale like porcelain skin
and a lot of people have speculated that
she put [ __ ] on her skin like lead-based
type of sets of make herself paler and
that that might have contributed to
illnesses I'm gonna ship out all the
Europeans you could be sitting there at
any minute talking to old Jimmy pull
reach behind him like that and pull out
of 45 1911 and open fire inside his own
shop shooting over the top of all the
lathes and all the all the milling
machines that he had into a into a snail
trap that he made which is a bullet trap
with the target over the end of it and
you start open fire in the middle of his
own shop it was like a size the large
garage he'd be talking to you shoot
[Music]
everybody go in there you know it was
into guns
our grizzly was the first 45 Winchester
Magnum pistol I'd ever seen he had that
thing cut down to the size of a 1911
which gun guys know exactly what I'm
talking about
it was beautiful one of the first guys I
knew he also had a Coonan 37 Magnum that
he actually modified it to work yeah
yeah the Coonan 37 magnums never worked
look out in 1911 but I shopped it to
seven Magnum was never really intended
to cycle in a pistol like that yeah cuz
that's a revolver cartridge but he got
it to work he got to work he cut enough
off of it and polished enough to get it
to work yeah yeah and they were
expensive back in those days okay so
anyway uh so the hospital itself they
actually had planned to build kind of a
university type thing or like a library
for all of Edgar Cayce's like teachings
they also wanted to focus on something
they called study groups which actually
edgar cayce got this idea when someone
asked him I believe it was a family
member that I suppose like hey why can't
we have them psychic powers like you
have and he's like yeah maybe anybody
can learn to do this and maybe we should
like organize study groups where people
can like practice and they can like get
up on it and like I said this is
something that they still do to this day
so that was kind of something they
wanted to do now the hospital was only
open for a couple of years then came the
Great Depression the hospital ended up
closing however the association that
they started the Institute that they
started which is called the Association
for research and enlightenment
ultimately is still around to this day
in Virginia Beach like I said it's their
headquarters they have a very nice
building and has a really nice big stone
labyrinth in the front there's classes
they do lectures and all kinds of [ __ ]
and it's still there if you're kind of
into that kind of stuff but so you know
there was that whole thing now um you
know there was a whole bunch of other
stuff about the you know the Institute
and like I said the classes and him
doing he kind of got more into doing you
know more metaphysical stuff and kind of
got out of the medical stuff a little
bit I think he still did it obviously
and actually when World War one came
around that's kind of when he started
like upping his workload because he
found that people
started writing him letters about their
relatives that were missing in action
and we're asking him where they were or
if he could help them or whatever and he
felt so bad that he was getting all
these letters and he wanted to help all
these people that he basically just
started doing all these readings like
all the time
and you know ended up not uh not really
getting any sleep or not getting any
rest or anything like that so apparently
like I said in his lifetime he did over
14,000 readings they didn't really start
keeping track of his readings or writing
them down until like the 1920s um
but by all sources say from June 1943 to
June 1944 he did almost 1,400 readings
and in August of 1944
Edgar Cayce pretty much just collapsed
because he was so tired from like
overwork and everything then this I
thought was kind of amusing but like in
a sad way like he gave himself a reading
and in his reading he said the quote was
rest until well we're dead yeah um a
couple months later sad to say it was
dead yeah he died he had a stroke and a
couple months later he died his wife
Gertrude died three months later
according to their son who like I said I
saw an interview with him when he was
much older obviously on one of the
documentaries and said you know she
after he died she didn't really have any
reason to live any more
she said she just died animals do that
too yes it's understandable like I said
is and particularly these two because
they had been married such a long time
she was such a big part of his not only
his life obviously but his business his
livelihood they did have a secretary
they called her a stenographer but she
was actually I mean she wrote down in
shorthand like every single thing he
said and like kept all the records like
all the letters she filed everything
I mean she's her name is Gladys Davis
and she's like kind of the reason that
so many people remember him because she
wrote every single thing down okay so
she kept his legacy alive right pretty
much but like I said Gertrude she was
always there she would be there when he
did the readings particularly in the
later years like after some of the other
like osteopaths and stuff had [ __ ] off
or done other things um
you know she was always there next to
him like helping him out so like I said
it was kind of one of those things where
once he died she was like well I guess
that's it for me too because she didn't
have anything else going on okay now all
of that said obviously there are a lot
of skeptics it was a lot of controversy
about Edgar Casey's claims about all the
stuff that he said um like you said he
very famously had a lot of [ __ ] to say
about Atlantis that he described as like
a very large cotton in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean
he actually said and forgive me if I'm
not getting this right but it did seem
like he said that between the years of
1958 and 1998 that both the east and
west coasts of the United States would
be destroyed he specifically pointed out
New York Los Angeles San Francisco
they'd be destroyed by being inundated
with water
although Atlantis would kind of rise to
the surface right good so obviously that
didn't happen because you know we're 20
years removed from that so he made
predictions like that um he also said
that Atlantis had been powered by a
giant solar crystal like I said he
famously claimed that in 1958 the United
States would find a death ray from
Atlantis and that we would use it like I
said we don't know if that's really true
or not he also had some weird ideas
about races like he he subscribed to the
idea that there were five human races
and they were all separate creations
which seems kind of a biblical yeah
thing you know so yeah so that doesn't
surprise me like a lot of the prophecies
that he made the Nostradamus II
prophecies that he prophesies that he
made seem particularly biblical like the
[ __ ] that he said about
you know the end of the world or things
like that now so they got out of
Revelations that's what I mean they all
sound very much like revelations which a
lot of Nostradamus is [ __ ] sounded like
that mad you know mother Shipton's [ __ ]
sounded like that it just sounded like
they were reading revelations and then
kind of changing the wording a little
bit all right
consider me yeah like at the end of the
millennium like lake of fire blah blah
blah like all this others like they were
just taking it right out of the Bible
but kind of like making it sound a
little bit different so it sounded yeah
kind of like more plausible I suppose so
original yeah so like a lot of his stuff
kind of sounded like that now one of the
documentaries that I saw on the History
Channel and like I said just came out
2005 The History Channel which used to
be fairly used to do just seems like
it's all monster week whatever year so I
history on this yeah I feel like it's
just gone the entire like reality Road
not much music on MTV they go is there
any I don't think and reality shows like
I said they're very cheap to produce and
people do seem to like them or they did
you know when that old cables kind of
winding down so this particular
documentary that I saw which came out in
2005 they stated okay first of all they
stated erroneously
that that Edgar Cayce had been involved
in like a company to dig for oil which
from from my other sources that was true
like I said he didn't like to get into
[ __ ] for financial reasons but
apparently this one person was able to
convince him hey why don't you tell me
like where to dig for oil will like have
an oil concern or whatever from my other
so therefore the other the other source
I said said you know yeah they were in
that business for three years and they
lost all their money because Edgar
Casey's predictions about where the oil
was were all wrong
right um which was in line with what he
said when I try to do it for profit it
doesn't work or I get wrong information
which you know what that is kind of an
see out though yeah they're like don't
come here and get me try to guess these
lottery numbers you know yeah because if
you're wrong you're right it's like hey
I thought you said you were psychic my
brow right yeah aren't you a millionaire
that kind of stuff
yeah for money so right so yeah it does
seem like an escape valve right but the
History Channel documentary very it
actually just glossed everything it's
like yeah he like said where all the oil
was and they were right and they made
all this money I'm like that's not what
I heard but you know I don't know I'm
just I'm not [ __ ] on you History
Channel not much well those programs are
quite deceptive you know not even quite
the same there are a lot deceptive yeah
because ancient aliens is one of them
comes to mind well here's the thing like
I watched that History Channel
documentary I'd watched another one that
had come out earlier that was actually
sympathetic to Edgar Cayce yeah that
specifically came out and said he opened
up this oil business is the other guy
but every single prediction he made
about what the oil was was wrong so if
even a documentary that was sympathetic
to him said that he was wrong about that
right I'd go with that so I'd go with
that because the History Channel was
just like yeah they made all this money
I'm like no they didn't he was a good
guy he was not a charlatan he was not
trying to do what l ron Hubbard did and
making money off of a big cult he was
just trying to heal people I do really
feel like that was his main focus and
Wright was just trying to help you and I
kind of think there was something to him
to a certain extent I mean if you're
trying to see visions of the past and
Atlantis you know you know even if you
could do that I'm gonna assume that your
visions are gonna be really really
contaminated with a lot of your own
ideas so your vision of the past might
be something that can't be translated
and written down accurately yeah a lot
of emotion to it probably right you know
kind of like like a dream
like visions so it's probably not gonna
be accurate so in his defense if he was
seeing the past maybe it wasn't accurate
okay yeah and then I believe he thought
he was yeah I never got the impression
that he was knowingly deceiving anybody
I never got that impression thought he
was and I believe that he believed that
he was healing people yeah
well honestly I think the best quote
unquote psychics are one that actually
believed that they have psychic powers
in his defense there didn't seem to be
anybody mad at him so most of the people
that dealt with him were satisfied with
the results yeah I kind of think he was
the kind of guy that if you met him face
to face
you'd like him and if you had a problem
he'd give you some good advice that
would probably work out yeah I'm feeling
that he was a guy like that I never in
all my like reading about him I never
came across anybody that said that
[ __ ] right everybody said he was
a lovely lovely man Roger I'm sure he
was so like I said and I never got the
impression that he was deliberately
trying to defraud anyone or anything
like that I think he legitimately did
believe he had that and he was
legitimately trying to just on the back
that he wasn't asking for a bunch of
money and that there wasn't a lot of
people that hated him I almost say there
was something to it yeah even if it was
just he was very intuitive or maybe he
listened to people but no one else did
even if it was all placebo effect yeah
or that too you know it might have been
because here's the thing where a lot of
skeptics like you know Martin Gardner
wrote about him Michael Shermer wrote
about him they're like we're not saying
that he didn't go into trances or
anything like that but you know we're
saying that he probably gleaned this
information from things that he had read
or things here but he was like
misinterpreting and like kind of you
know rearranging the information in a
way that seemed like it was prophetic or
seemed like it was coming out of nowhere
when it wasn't actually because he was
like a big reader like I said even
though the New York Times said called
him illiterate quote-unquote I saw the
headline he was not illiterate by any
stretch the imagination he had read Carl
Jung he had read Madame Blavatsky he had
read all that stuff so he understood
the stuff about you know kind of a you
know human conscious in this type of
thing where everyone can kind of plug
into it he understood you know various
medical terms he understood stuff he you
know he was friends with osteopaths and
stuff so he knew like at the terminology
so he could like repeat that back to
people in a way that made sense to them
and you know if their illness was
perhaps not that dire or if it went away
on its own or whatever and they did what
he asked them to do and it you know
maybe it didn't do anything but maybe
they got better afterward and they
attributed it to that because the
problem is that all of this stuff about
him is as I said anecdotal it's all
testimonials it's all anything right as
they say it really new anecdotes are not
data you can't you know there's no
double-blind studies there's no you know
there's no way of checking up and a lot
of the stuff about him comes from people
who knew him biographers people who were
friends of his so how much of that stuff
is accurate you know there's really no
way of knowing and like I said you know
all the stuff that was written down of
all the stuff that he said when he was
in a trance you know you don't know what
happened to that person that wrote that
letter that said oh they had cancer and
like he said this that and the other
thing you don't know if that person died
or not you don't know if they did the
treatment that he told them to do you
don't know any of that right so it seems
like as much as you know yes his
writings were voluminous like everything
that he said but there's really no way
of checking up on most of it so there's
no way of knowing how much of it it was
a long time was helpful or accurate it
was a long time ago they didn't have
mass communication leader or master
minute
telecommunication was kind of difficult
yeah but we do know that he wasn't being
sued by a lot of people yes that's that
kinda goes in his favor he did get
arrested for fortune-telling but I think
he got off on it okay but because that
was illegal and there weren't then there
doesn't seem to be any complaints about
him yeah well not that I could find
but like I said harder dealing with
people that want it to be true I tend I
tend to believe that he is a mixture of
folk remedies that were effective yeah
placebo yeah and good bedside manner be
a good way I think that's a good way key
had a good personality we when you met
him face to face and he made you feel
better and he did help you and tried to
help you you know yeah and yeah he had a
good success rate yeah for one reason or
another be it a a folk remedy that he
knew about or if it was a placebo thing
maybe the problem wasn't sickness maybe
it was in your mind in the placebo yeah
and maybe just resting or taking a blood
bath or maybe that helped you know
because maybe it was like stress-related
yeah it was a lot of that kind of so um
I'm just gonna kind of wrap it up from
for me I think he was a successful
healer yeah alright for some reason in
this is hard to madam he genuinely
seemed to care about other people's
welfare and did want to help them right
now he wasn't a surgeon no okay we're
not saying that you know I mean well at
least he wasn't pretending to be he
wasn't pretending wasn't pretending to
be he was kind of like a general
practitioner he was just giving advice
you could take it or leave it right so
he wasn't I mean yes some of the advice
might have been it was like bones bones
or McCoy from Star Trek just a country
doctor he was like a general practice
like maybe the advice he gave which
probably could have been detrimental to
the person we don't know I'm sure it was
in some cases because some of the stuff
he prescribed is a little iffy but you
know there's no way of knowing that at
this point it didn't seem to kill them
though but well not well but we don't
know that I don't know that we don't
know that yeah so like I said there was
a lot of readings there were no exactly
no one ever accuse well if you die you
can't complain but the relatives trail
you know but maybe the relatives didn't
now I'm just saying there's a lot of
factors that could be this is why you
need to take something
that talent you have to put them in a
lab and test them like in controlled
conditions because otherwise you'll
never know if anything like that
happened it wasn't it was by accident I
think you know Casey wasn't trying to
kill he was you know he was well and he
did seem to worry about that so he
wasn't a monster I mean he didn't like
have a conscience it's like that's the
other cat that's amazing
she's like coming in here she's kind of
edgy she's she's old and not having any
[ __ ] you show them yeah she's not that
old she's 10 yeah but yeah she's not
having anymore so you know like I said I
kind of was there was on actually Edgar
Casey's like the Association like actual
official website they have like some
prophecies that he made that haven't
been fulfilled yet just kind of your
standard stuff about humans a live a
really long time will invent a perpetual
motion machine Second Coming type stuff
like I said it's a lot of it's very
bubbly you could tell it comes from like
a Christian from that time worldview and
from that time period you know he he
makes prophecies about really obvious
[ __ ] like Oh conflict in the Persian
Gulf I'm like yeah what else is new yeah
that's going on a long time it's like
every you know profit worth their salt
is you know that's a pretty safe but
also you know kind of stuff like that
and we also mentioned the Akashic
records and all that kind of stuff being
discovered and whatnot what she says is
under the paw of the Sphinx so now that
you kind of put it in the in the opening
you said he was the other Nostradamus
now I'm kind of seeing that he was
although Nostradamus didn't really as
far as I know have a reputation for
healing people
well he was a doctor you started out as
a doctor he was a doctor yeah I guess he
became a prophet later yeah okay which
was kind of the same thing I mean Edgar
Cayce was obviously not trained as a
physician he didn't supposedly know
anything about this he started out doing
that kind of stuff just like folk
medicine type stuff and then later went
into the whole prophecy thing you know
on the advice of others as far as I can
determine
yeah you know what you would say folk
medicine you know kind of dented
it's in a way you know a lot of folk
medicine there was something to it a lot
of them oh yes oh I don't mean to
denigrate it at all I do think that a
lot of stuff a lot of people do do kind
of denigrate yeah I know a lot of the
folk remedies okay actually had
medicinal essence for them you know and
they're using things that are like
aspirin or anti-inflammatories and you
know so yeah the [ __ ] does work
somebody's worked but some of it yeah
and some of it is just you know it's
that kind of thing where it's like oh I
feel a cold coming out I'll take a Vitus
vitamin C tablet that doesn't do
anything but I mean it's not gonna hurt
you
right it just doesn't do anything well
it might improve your situation from
SIBO from placebo effect because you
feel like it's gonna feel better so yeah
so you can't [ __ ] on it in that sense
because the police say placebo effect is
a real thing it has been demonstrated so
that is a real thing so I think that's
kind of what was going on here like I
said I never got the impression that he
was trying to you know [ __ ] anybody over
or try to get money out of people cuz he
apparently never really did try to do
that he was just trying to help people
and I don't know if he really had any
psychic powers or any kind of special
powers or anything but apparently a lot
of people think he did and a lot of
people think that he helped them so I'm
not gonna get too upset about it
you know and like I said his foundation
is still around to this day so I mean
there was she's glasses in ESP or
something like that and there is
something underneath the foot of the
face of the paulus things I would like
to know what that is he did call that
yeah although if you call you you call
out enough stuff chances are someone
we're gonna hit right that's that's
another thing too is that from a
statistical standpoint particularly if
you're a psychic and one of the first
things and this is one of the first
thing that the skeptic will tell you to
when they're doing cold readings or hot
readings or whatever they're like make a
lot of pretty talk a lot yeah
because eventually you're gonna come up
with something that's gonna hit and
people will forget everything that you
[ __ ] up and you'll just remember right
things I gots narrowing it down
right to that channel cuz that's just
the way human brains work like I said
you can [ __ ] up things all day long but
the second you get something specific
right that's the only thing that was
Dennis psyching income Ron says well
that's how psychic powers work just like
how they always say it's like well it
doesn't work like when you try to like
you're thinking about it too much right
all right so let's wrap up this show
about Edgar Cayce I hope you guys
enjoyed it like I said I can't remember
who requested it but thank you for
requesting it because I probably
wouldn't have thought of it on my own
even though he's like super famous but
but so anyway I hope you guys enjoyed it
and remember if you like the show to
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support this show please go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
so you know there will be like new stuff
coming new videos new you know early
access to episodes and stuff like that
so go check it out if you don't like
patreon but you would still like to
financially support the show you can
give a one-time donation at our PayPal
account which you can find there's a
link at our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast at WordPress com and there's a
little link in the sidebar that will go
to a PayPal account if you'd like to be
a one-time donation also remember our
regular episodes come out every Tuesday
and movie retrospective usually old
movies that comes out every Friday and
our 13 o'clock matinee show which is
three new movies in the theater that
comes out every Sunday so check them out
if you haven't already and we will see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]